- Is it true that you were
a banana delivery girl
in New Zealand?
- I think I was the first, yeah.
The first official banana
delivery person in Wellington.
I used to ride around on a scooter,
and I had this stack of banana boxes
on the back of my scooter,
and then unfortunately I blew over.
It's a very windy city.
I blew over twice outside the same cafe,
so I moved to a hearse,
and I was delivering
bananas out of a hearse
for a little while.
- Is a hearse the same thing
in New Zealand as it is here?
- Yeah, that's not a lost
in translation thing.
That's, like, you put
a coffin in the back.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Yeah.
- Delivering bananas?
- [Rose] Yep, exactly.
- Did people want the
bananas from a hearse?
- They didn't actually
know the details, Kelly.
- Okay, okay.
You're like, just pulling up,
and they're like, "Wait, what?"
- It's a trick of the trade.
I'm like, "Guys, don't be alarmed.
It's not what you think. No emergency."
- [Kelly] It's bananas!
- Bananas! It's a great day.
- I love that.
Another thing that you
did early in your career
is you wanted to be a rapper, right?
Were you rapping?
- I did. I won't put
you through that today.
I wasn't like one of those people
who was sitting on a wealth of
talent that was undiscovered.
It wasn't like one of those
stories you're gonna hear
where like, "I can't believe
she didn't get scouted!"
- My God, you're like
a comedian! Oh my God!
- No, I was a terrible rapper,
a terrible rapper, but-
- [Kelly] Who were your favorites?
- Well, growing up by the beach,
Bohemian kind of New Zealand lifestyle,
I discovered Tupac and
finally felt really seen.
- [Kelly] Oh my God!
- [Rose] Yeah.
I don't know why him.
- [Kelly] You related?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] You related to
the core messages there?
- Yep, yep.
- (laughs) That's amazing!
You should be a comedian!
- (laughs) You're so kind!
- [Kelly] You're so funny!
- Oh, gosh.
- Oh my God, I love you!